j'ai jamais connu les restaurants depuis
ces dernières depuis confinement j'ai
jamais connu des restaurants aussi
propre aussi propre manette et on n'a
jamais désinfecter des tables avant
quand on a les restaurants les tables
sont désinfectés il ya du gel ya les
espaces alors il faut ils ont peut-être
pas fait là ils ont fait la demande
ils sont trompés entre les péniches les
soirées où tu bois des mojitos tu tu
embrasses où tout le monde est un peu
éméché avec un restaurant il ya derrière
ça va être un drame alors c'est sa
demande et des baskets avec nous bonsoir
bonsoir philippe merci d'être là
philippe vraiment merci et et on
comprend vraiment votre désarroi et j'ai
vu plein de gens aujourd'hui plein de
potes qui ont des bâtons des restaurants
qui est que j'ai eues en pleurs au
téléphone qui m'ont dit si rien moi ces
dix années 20-30 ans travail qui part en
poussière je sais que je me relèverai
plus c'est l'histoire d'une vie pour
beaucoup de gens pour beaucoup de
familles ça c'est terrible
imaginez vous la tous autour de du
plateau là vous êtes tous les bons
vivants imaginer qu'un jour ne puissiez
plus jamais mangé au restaurant vont
aller boire un coup dans un bar qu'est
ce que vous feriez métro boulot dodo
c'est ce qui va se passer on vrai et le
lien social il va être rompu ça va être
terrible
alors on peut pas après rivaliser avec
la santé parce qu'il est important de la
santé j'entends mais comment aujourd'hui
en 2020 on à avoir à choisir entre la
santé et l'économie
ça je ne le comprends pas ensuite pour
rebondir sur ce qu'a dit monsieur
guillard
oui dans les tgv pour qu'on ait six ans
mais je veux rajouter un truc pourquoi
dans les trains ou les plus de 600 et
qu'en plus on peut manger dans les
trains ça arrive maintenant explique t
il a raison ça philippe ça c'est ça
c'est une vraie question mine de rien
parce que même si on peut plus manger au
bar on peut manger la grosse c'est qu'à
l'hôtel tu peux faire le tu peux manger
à l'hôtel mai à 9 heures faute je rentre
dans ta chambre
et c'est de battre philippe etchebest
qu'elle quelles seraient vos sauts de
choses que vous avez essayé je sais que
vous avez eu un moment où l'on vous
voyez vous concernant vous en avez parlé
qu'edouard finit pas l'époque avec
l'ancien premier ministre
quelles sont les solutions pour les
restaurateurs parce que là on voit il
n'y a pas de solution pour huit mois est
obligé de fermer si tu penses que ça va
être pour un mois un mois et demi encore
au moins voire même je pense un peu plus
et ça va être une catastrophe
les solutions elles sont question les
solutions et il ya eu
z qui ont été données à un moment donné
pendant premier confinement des êtres
qui n'ont pas suffi vous imaginez au
départ c'était 1500 euros pour certains
restaurateurs attention pas tous
d'accord avec les 500 euros quand vous
avez trois mille 4000 euros de loyer
quand vous avez quatre mille 4000 euros
de frais fixes à payer et que vous ne
vous versez même pas de salaire faut
juste lui expliquer comment on fait
qu'ils supporteraient aujourd'hui de ne
pas être payés pendant plus de sept mois
pendant plus de sept mois et c'est une
réalité
est ce que est ce qu'un fonctionnaire
l'acceptez est ce qu'un médecin accepte
presque à un professeur personnes
accepterait ça et pourtant dans notre
métier ça arrive
il ya des gens aujourd'hui qui ne se
verse plus de salaire depuis sept mois
alors aujourd'hui ce qui se passe c'est
une mise à mort de notre profession
d'une grande partie de la profession
il ya plusieurs mois j'ai annoncé deux
cent cinquante mille pertes d'emplois
30% de faillite on y va et droit mais
met carrément on va droit dans le mur et
je pense c'est une estimation optimiste
que j'ai et elle était elle a été
révélée par l'insee sur les premiers sim
semestre il y avait 140 4000 chômage
supplémentaire la sodexo qui est une
grosse boîte a fait 2000 suppressions
d'emplois là donc vous vous rendez
compte
ça concerne tout le monde les petits et
les gros mais il se trouve
qu'aujourd'hui il y avait beaucoup de
totti les tpe elles sont énormes et à
160 milles en france et c'est quand même
grave à ce qui se passe aujourd'hui ce
sont des fans qui vont être détruites et
caen et caen et quand le gouvernement et
plusieurs scientifiques disent que c'est
obligatoire parce qu'aujourd'hui le
restaurant les barques c'est trop
dangereux et c'est pour pour le virus on
est obligé pour arrêter la propagation
du virus vous leur répondez quoi si je
peux me permettre une chose moi je suis
pas scientifique je ne suis pas médecin
d'accord j'ai lu un rapport de nagoya
qui dit les clusters la grosse partie
des classes à la vienne des universités
des collèges du foyer des foyers privés
aussi parce que qu'est ce qui va
empêcher les gens aujourd'hui de se
réunir chez eux sans aucune prétention
sans aucun geste barrière nous ne
sécurisons quand même les clients notre
lente et les données personnelles
comparé hier son respect
non on est plusieurs restaurants minute
chez soi voulu si vous aviez un dernier
mot à dire ce soir à noter les
régulateurs et un message à faire passer
avec moi philippe qui dit que c'est
interdit si je voulais dire un dernier
message à faire passer égard cela dit
façon on n'a pas le choix aujourd'hui on
voit bien qu'on a pas le choix on subit
les choses maintenant ce que j'ai envie
de dire c'est pas aux téléspectateurs ce
gouvernement est à nos syndicats de se
battre de se battre pour nous de s'unir
deneux de ne faire qu'une seule voix et
surtout après ses décisions qu'il faut
assumer
mais c'est d'aider la profession mais de
l'aider pour de vrai exactement
merci en tout cas philippe un brave
qu'est ce que vous faites vous dire je
sais qu'ils se battent tous les jours
pour tous les restaurateurs pas les
filles pour vraiment je vais vous dire
chapeau pour ce que vous faites et
continuez à vous battre et vraiment je
sais comme vous devez avoir plein de
potes aussi qui qui sont vraiment dans
une situation inextricable et vous aussi
ça doit vous miner tous les jours comme
nous ici
et bravo à vous de vous battre et
d'essayer de faire
[Applaudissements]